bonjour monsieur merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui sur rt france alors la
principale opposante un d'alexandre
loukachenko à svetlana tirade riskaya
appel emmanuel macron a joué un rôle de
médiateur est ce que le président
français peut-il doit-il remplir ce rôle
je crois que celle de propositions
qu'ils soient médiateur est un mauvais
choix pour être médiateur il faut être
dessus d'un esprit partisan
lorsque manuel macro critique la
situation réelle russie je n'ai pas
entendu lever le petit doigt pour
critiquer le coup d'état en bolivie ni
soutenir le venezuela par rapport à
l'attitude américaine d'imposer un
président content fétiche ou et d'eau
donc je pense que ce sera lui peut pas
jouer il peut pas jouer d'autant qu'il
est un clic et dans beaucoup d'autres
affaires pour le moins discutable
cueillis sont eux qui s'appelle le liban
qui s'appelle la syrie la libye et c'est
un choix à mon avis très contestable on
a appris il ya quelques secondes
emmanuel macron rencontrera cette lan à
tirana scaglia si elle en fait la
demande
est ce que à votre avis et même là qu'on
doit rencontrer cette cette opposante au
pouvoir emmanuel macron il est
incontrôlable incontrôlable sur toutes
les choses la gueule au niveau intérieur
au niveau international je crois que
surtout il essaye d'exister
malheureusement à chaque fois qu'il
essaye d'exister et s'aggravent au
niveau mon personnel parce que ça fait
toujours une situation plus conflictuel
il alla et la manière de se mettre tout
le monde à dos alors maintenant il peut
rencontrer l'opposante à l'occassion co
mais il devrait d'ailleurs balayer
devant chez lui
il devrait encore connaître les
oppositions france et des rencontres et
donc à partir de là il aurait déjà un
visage différent d'une attitude
différente d'un point de vue politique
alors emmanuel macron 1 seront
aujourd'hui
pardon en lituanie quelle est la
stratégie du président de la république
à votre avis écoutez c'est un très
mauvais choix lituanie et estonie
lorsqu'on regarde un peu le comportement
de ces deux pays baltes on peut pas dire
que ce soient des exemples de démocratie
particulièrement illustratif
on a même remis en vigueur l'honorable
parcours de certains nazi dans ces pays
donc je crois que de ce point de vue il
devrait quand même leur demander
pourquoi ils ont fait ça avant de
demander à loukachenko pourquoi sa
réaction par rapport au peuple et celle
là donc on prêt beaucoup discuté de ça
mais à mon avis c'est une erreur une
erreur qui correspond je dirais à deux
choses d'abord la pression de l'union
européenne qui veut absolument mettre
des sanctions en place contre la bey'a
re sic mais demandent pas du tout la
levée des sanctions dans les autres pays
deuxième aspect c'est le commandant le
gendarme américain en europe et il veut
absolument être comment dire un allié
privilégié de l'otan'' et il ne le plat
preuve c'est qu'il ya des soldats
stationnés à la frontière devaient lui
or ici dans ces pays là mais eux ils
s'offusquent pas que moi qui suis un
fils de résistants qui lui mieux
autorise à nouveau 81 ans après des
soldats allemands un maître pieds sur
terre en france c'est quand même deux
points de vue et lorsqu'on a une figure
de moraliste
on essaye d'être parfait dans son
attitude de miroirs merci beaucoup josé
evrard d'avoir été avec nous cet après
midi sur arte france je rappelle que
vous êtes député de la 3e
circonscription du pas-de-calais membres
du parti les patriotes merci beaucoup